la frontière quatrième partie
l'évolution des frontières en références
bibliographiques pour la réalisation de
cet exposé le dictionnaire de géographie
nos éditions à petit on pourrait penser
que les frontières ont toujours existé
et qu'il s'agit d'un phénomène
relativement stable ce n'est pas le cas
quand on regarde la planche 59e de votre
place on peut remarquer que si l'on
prend comme référence ici 1870 très peu
de frontières européennes existent
depuis cette date en effet au niveau de
l'europe
vous voyez que les frontières belges
évidemment existe depuis 1870 la
frontière entre l'espagne et le portugal
les frontières suisses ainsi que
certaines frontière franco italienne au
nord de l'europe le meur des pays
scandinaves connaissent aussi une
stabilité de leurs frontières et enfin
une frontière à l'est n'a pas été
modifié depuis 1870 il s'agit de la
frontière entre la roumanie la bulgarie
toutes les autres frontières ont évolué
depuis 1870 par cela même on trouve que
ce phénomène n'est pas forcément stable
et qu'il évolue
intéressons nous tout d'abord à la
naissance des frontières les frontières
vont être de trois événements tout
d'abord après un conflit les
belligérants peuvent se mettre autour de
la table pour négocier de nouvelles
frontières ou souvent c'est le vainqueur
qui impose de nouveaux tracés au vaincu
c'est le cas de la première guerre
mondiale où par exemple l'alsace
lorraine va être retirée de l'allemagne
pourraient être intégrées à la france
avec bien sûr un nouveau tracé de
frontières ça peut être aussi le fait
d'une guerre civile à la fin d'une
guerre civile
on va mettre en place de nouvelles
frontières comme par exemple entre
l'ethiopie et l'erythrée
la frontière peut être aussi des suites
d'une grande conférence internationale
par exemple les nations colonisatrices
vont incertain avant négocier de
nouvelles frontières ou imposer de
nouvelles frontières qui vont être liée
à la décolonisation
on a aussi le cas du démantèlement de
l'autriche hongrie en 1918 ou plus
récemment la création de la palestine en
mais cette création ces nouvelles
frontières ne sont pas acceptés par tous
et peuvent être directement contestées
comme c'est le cas en effet pour la
palestine
ensuite on aura aussi une évolution en
période de paix mais c'est plus rare
le dernier exemple en date est même en
1993 la fin de la tchécoslovaquie qui va
faire une séparation on va appeler de
velours parce qu'elles se passent sont
de très bons termes ou les tchèques vont
se séparer des slovaques et donc il y
aura l'apparition d'une nouvelle
frontière entre la république tchèque et
la slovaquie commence va se construire
la frontière tout d'abord on a là une
affaire politique
un qui est lié à la négociation les
différentes nations où les différentes
entités vont se mettent d'accord et vont
définir cette frontière
ensuite il y aura un travail de
biographe de cartographes plutôt qu'ils
vont à partir des cartes à partir des
plans décider du tracé réel de cette
frontière
enfin il y aura un travail de terrain
qui va faire qu'on va mettre des marques
sur cette frontière lui donner un peu de
consistance
on va aller sur les lieux est souvent
utilisé certains marqueurs pour définir
clairement la frontière souvent des
routes servent vraiment de frontières ça
peut arriver régulièrement une fois
qu'elle est définie une fois qu'elle
existe la frontière peut s'ouvrir ou se
fermer lorsque une frontières s'ouvrent
on va constater de nombreux mouvements
migratoires des personnes qui sont dans
une zone de conflits vont vouloir la
quitter des personnes éloignées de leurs
familles vont à ce moment-là repasser la
frontière pour rejoindre
leurs familles les touristes vont
éventuellement se diriger vers cette
nouvelle
ces nouvelles contrées qui va offrir un
petit peu des curiosités jusque là
inédites
c'est le cas par exemple de l'iran avec
qui les occidentaux pour l'instant on
vraiment son situation d'apaisement
avant c'était vraiment le grand ennemi
l'iran maintenant ça devient vraiment un
partenaire économique voire militaire et
donc de plus en plus de tour opérateurs
proposent des voyages en iran donc
évidemment cette ouverture peut être
plus ou moins brusque et plus elle sera
brusque évidemment plus les phénomènes
migratoires seront de grande ampleur à
l'opposé on peut avoir une frontière qui
étaient ouverts qui va se fermer
alors évidemment là il ya des
conséquences désastreuses pour les
espaces frontaliers puisque ceux ci
comme on l'a vu dans la vidéo précédente
devons tirer profit des disparités qui
existent grâce à la frontière à partir
du moment où la frontière n'existe plus
belle ces espaces frontaliers perte
leurs atouts et finalement vont se
retrouver à être destitué des des lieux
périphériques qui n'ont plus aucune
importance
on a vraiment le passage d'un lieu de
grande activité à un espace vraiment
périphérique qu'il n'y a plus aucun
intérêt
enfin on pourrait aussi constaté la
disparition de certaines frontières
ça arrive souvent dans deux cas alors et
à la disparition pure et simple
quand deux états fusionnent c'est le ça
a été le cas au yemen le yémen du nord
qui va certainement fusionné avec le
yémen du sud pour former le yémen ou
encore le vietnam après la guerre du
vietnam dans les années 60
dans un autre cas on va simplement avoir
une atténuation de la frontière c'est ce
qui se passe par exemple dans une
intégration économique comme nous le
connaissons en europe avec la
construction européenne et l'apparition
de l'union européenne ou par exemple en
amérique du nord avec l'alena
les frontières à ce moment là perte
vraiment leurs fonctions de démarcation
de différenciation de deux économies par
exemple puisque dans le cas d'une
intégration économique
on aura plus qu'un seul espace
économique voilà cette vidéo est ici
terminer je vous propose de passer au
petit quizz et bien sûr de réserver vos
questions pour le prochain cours au
revoir à bientôt